[Musique]
le moment est venu de faire revivre le
parc
une nouvelle journée commence au parc
des merveilles toute l'équipe se prépare
boomer l'ours d'accueil steve le
responsable de la sécurité en gare de
biot les bras à l'intérieur du véhicule
et pin est l'inventeur d'attraction nous
allons inaugurer le grand manège avec
ses chevaux je suis sûr qu'on peut faire
mieux
oui tu as raison je crois que pinata
plus d'imagination des poissons les
poissons volants et en appuyant sur
leurs nageoires vous pourrez voler au
dessus des marques tu dis pas
quelquefois que le parc existant vrai
mais oui pourquoi pas tu peux réaliser
tout ce que tu imagines paramount
animations et nickelodeon movies
présente
qu'est ce que ça fait là
ici le parc de vos rêves je suis dans le
parc des merveilles
réalité bon allez on se calme je
m'appelle john j'ai inventé le parc des
merveilles quand j'étais petit
pourquoi tu as choisi importe pic pour
assurer la sécurité j'ai l'impression de
m'être engagé dans une impasse
arrêté le 3 avril
je comprends pas ce qui est arrivé ici
en grandissant les enfants ne croient
plus aux histoires et l'imagination
disparaît c'est comme ça que le rêve a
tourné au cauchemar n'en rajoute pas à
tende alpes
[Musique]
pour faire renaître la magie le moment
est venu de faire revivre le parc
on est en train d'exciter un miracle
l'imagination prend le pouvoir
vous avez bien bloqué les roues les
roues ça sert à bloquer les routes ça
bon rouge
[Musique]
avec tout le monde
à ce stade et je crois que l'on peut
parler de situation désespérée et non je
conjure le parc des merveilles au cinéma
le 3